and now appr propo of this conversation
the last gasp of the never trumpers
that's the focus of tonight's
angle all right whatever the final tally
tonight is in New Hampshire Donald J
Trump is well on his way to being the
GOP 2024 nominee now this is nothing
personal toward the former South
Carolina governor as our reporter Brian
yanis just said she's been working hard
in the granite state but if she decides
to drag this out through South Carolina
or Beyond Trump will still be the
nominee it doesn't matter how many
donors or paid flaks tell Nikki Haley
otherwise this is not her time now it's
funny to watch the corporate media
though because they're so predictable
all she needs to do is outperform in New
Hampshire whatever that
means Haley on the other hand hoping to
shatter expectations telling reporters
she's in it for the long run Nikki Haley
is making what could be her last stand
betting her hopes on crushing the
numbers of Undeclared voters and doing
better than expected with
Republicans well it's nice try but guess
who sets the expectations the corporate
media so the Press is so desperate to
keep the appearance of a horse race that
they had this banner up on MSNBC pretty
much all day I love it
100% for Nikki Haley 0% for Trump okay
of course it's dixville Notch you know
they had that at the bottom of the
screen all six voted for Nikki Haley
four of the voters were registered
Republicans the other two Undeclared you
see Haley out to a quick 60 lead
courtesy of dixville Notch where all six
voters uh had their traditional midnight
vote last night dixville Notch obviously
just after midnight all six votes in
that place uh voted for Nikki
haly okay news flash you need to win in
order to chalk up delegates and as
someone who spent four years and four
Winters in New Hampshire I'll tell you
this if she cannot win a primary in a
state like New Hampshire where the
independence can vote where she has the
governor on her side and where social
conservatives have little influence
where exactly does she plan to win as
much as y'all like to sit there and say
Trump's going to have this the truth is
you're not acknowledging that 70% of
Americans don't want a trump bid and
rematch Trump has lied on TV and spent
Millions saying I want to cut Social
Security which I never said I I saw that
yesterday yeah but you guys haven't
talked about it keep saying coronate lie
not tell the truth what are you say in
the catch I'm really wondering why you
think we're the enemy because I've
looked at the media look at the
political class all coalescing and
saying everybody needs to get
out of course I understand that it has
to be disappointing to learn that in
most Republican uh voter strongholds
they don't agree with you on some key
issues the so-called mainstream GOP has
had what about eight and a half years to
convince the voters that Trump was wrong
about China wrong about immigration
wrong about Foreign Affairs wrong about
the Deep state but despite their best
efforts people like McConnell Romney
chrisy and Mike Pence they couldn't
convince the voters to turn away from
the America first or populist agenda in
fact if anything the less support Trump
got from the so-called moderates the
more voters views solidified in his
favor so why has this happened why don't
the voters trust the GOP leadership and
the so-called mainstream well it's not
hard the Senate minority leader right
now is working with Chuck Schumer to
squeeze out more money for Ukraine and
essentially keep the Border open calling
it a big border deal even though poll
after poll shows that the GOP voters do
not want either no wonder they don't
trust the party leadership you can't
blame them the GOP uh the Biden
Administration is literally suing right
now to stop Texas from enforcing the
Border yeah somehow Senate Republicans
think Biden can be trusted to enforce
any new laws it makes zero sense and the
voters know this now Haley isn't asking
for my opinion and she's smithed at this
network but it's kind of
obvious if you're a republican who is
seen as standing defiantly against your
own voters on key issues you're probably
not going to be too popular Republicans
want a candidate who reflects their
views and of course they also want to
win my vote this morning I went instead
of voting for Haley I voted for Donald
Trump this morning you vote this morning
why um I think the election the primary
is over I think that you know Mr Trump's
going to be our next
candidate well smart guy even Politico
yesterday called Haley's New Hampshire
bid The Last Stand of the never trumpers
and the GOP chair in New Hampshire
Jennifer horn just Flatout said it's all
over now never trumpers do see New
Hampshire as a make or break moment
right they we we know that but as I said
wishing it were different doesn't make
it
different so now what's at stake why is
this happening well we know tonight that
you're going to hear a lot of chatter
about continuing to continuing to go
continuing to keep this going on but in
the end we're seeing why Donald Trump
ultimately won
this he won this because he won the
heart and soul of the Republican
voters and that's on issue after issue
after indictment after
indictment and doesn't matter what Nikki
Haley believes at this point doesn't
matter if she decides to stay in she'll
either be part of the solution for
restoring prosperity and peace to the
United States or she'll be part of the
problem I hope for her it's the former
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else